[Music]
that is david perrico the leader of the
raiders house band at legion stadium and
he is one busy man with the start of the
raider season and an upcoming
performance at the smith center welcome
to the show my friend great to be here
was that david bowie let's dance your
plane that's what it was oh that's
simple how did you get the gig as the
leader of the the raiders house band
it was quite a process uh contacted
through um raiders organization to come
down and it was uh an audition process
that started in june are you a raiders
fan no i am
so what's the official name of the band
well they're still working on that
branding it might be david perrico in
the raider house band
and then there's a whole list of other
possibilities what an honor it is and
you're such a talented guy and so well
deserving that you have this this new
gig with the raiders and stuff so what
can we expect at the games you'll be
playing in and out of uh timeouts and
everything commercial breaks yeah expect
us to play a set um pre-game 45 minutes
wow yeah a nice mix of uh songs and then
throughout the game we'll be playing
commercial breaks and touchdowns and
stuff like that you're now a las vega
already been a las vegas picture now
you're gonna be a fixture at the raiders
games and you have a show coming up at
the smith center what can we expect at
the smith center we're doing a theme
concert jazz and strings uh and we're um
augmenting the orchestra to 16 strings
all female string section and uh a lot
of standards like nat cole natalie cole
frank sinatra gershwin that kind of
stuff you covered all so something a
little different
and you're yeah you got vegan an ohio
guy but you got vegas connections you
graduated from unlv graduated from unlv
uh did my master's degree finished in
2006. and you performed all around the
world with so many great people i have a
list of some people that you've
performed with what i'm going to do is i
mention the name and you kind of give me
out of one or two words to describe that
person he performed with right okay uh
barry manilow dynamic
tony braxton
amazing you performed with bb king what
was that like legendary
drew where did you perform at drew carey
oh we did a show in la with the lawn
bronson band wow yeah and uh it was
great to meet drew and uh
i think you're gonna say you're on the
prices right that's how you're
performing drew carey no i thought the
price is wrong
and you said you were in last comic
standing
yeah performing or yeah yeah doing stand
up
no just performing in the house band
okay yeah well we're excited about the
smith center show and then performing
for the raiders anything special for
that first game on september 13th yeah
first game look for a lot of uh
different um
rock rock music we're going to do we
embellish the band with adding horns
like the tower of power sound and look
for a new arrangement on the monday
night football theme oh that's going to
be awesome david we're looking forward
to it you got the show at the smith
center and of course we'll see them all
season long at the raiders games thank
you so much my pleasure thank you
mercedes will send it over